welcome back this morning we're talking
about women's health especially as women
age you know sometimes it's still a
taboo topic to talk about the change but
not today joining me the founders of
womanist Sally Miller Michelle Jacobs
are here spreading a word about what you
guys call I love this menop positivity
so ladies you are the face behind this
incredible brand that's all over stores
Ulta Target very affordable brand but
you're here today to really talk about
your story and to bust the menopause
myth so let's jump into it let's kind of
talk about some of the signs that we
should be looking for early before
menopause begins what do we need to
start looking for as the early or as the
beginning yeah so that early stage is
called perimenopause and it can be
anywhere from two to ten years leading
up to menopause okay and some of those
early signs include irregular periods so
if you've normally had a regular period
and it doesn't seem right it seems
really irregular that's an early sign
wait gain hormonal acne is surprisingly
an early sign of menopause also night
sweats hot flashes you can still get all
of that stuff even if you're not
officially in menopause which is 12
months without getting your period okay
so it can start and like you said what
two to ten years yes that's a long time
to be dealing with those types of
symptoms and not have what you might say
is an official uh diagnosis or if you
will let's bust some myths because there
are a lot of myths out there about
menopause so let's talk about some of
the things that you hear over and over
again yes that menopause is just hot
flashes and that is a myth it's so much
more there's over 40 symptoms of
menopause oh boy absolutely so most
women actually don't complain as much
about hot flashes I mean it they do but
it's not the most you know biggest issue
I should say so it's changing skin it's
low libido it's sleepless nights it's
you know weight gang as Michelle said so
there's so many other symptoms in
addition to hot flashes and that's tough
because not a single one of those things
is a desirable character right that we
want to be living through and dealing
with and going through our everyday life
because we know how busy women are so
now you guys have all of these um kind
of nutritional products and supplements
and creams but you're also really big
into education and inspiration so let's
talk about that and what women s does to
help out women is we're going through
this process of Aging yeah it doesn't
have to be a tough time in your life you
can have friends people helping you out
along the way we have a private Facebook
group called The After Party where women
share information share their own
experiences and tips and ideas how to
talk to a doctor how to what products
should I be buying what are the
solutions you really need so we have
that and then on top of it on our own
website on womanist.com WE interview
doctors we have tons of information
about what's going on in your body where
you are in this phase of Life the
symptoms of are there some but you're
not alone everybody goes through it
right and it's really helpful to have
other people there with you and to have
that open dialogue and open conversation
and guys you have to listen you have to
understand so ladies thank you so much
for being here Sally and Michelle of
woman s and of course you can find these
Target Ulta yes they're under 40. it's
very affordable all of our skin care is
under thirty dollars our supplement
um around 25 to 40 dollars that's all
it's very affordable and so helpful for
women as we age let's talk about it get
on the Facebook group ladies thanks for
coming in thank you very much ladies at
home hang tight we'll be right back